hey I can't really I can't really talk
right now
I'm about to run out of those vitamins
big gay me so did you guys get to meet
the candidates stringer seems like a
real tool no they just breezed right by
us we are out here on the loading dock
worst job ever
so are you gonna give me this Mike
that's a lot
vitamins dude I gave you like fifty
three weeks ago okay now I need like 51
I can't keep using Campbell's
prescription pad look I get you like ten
more but that's it you really got to
ease up on this stuff it's on too much
longer we have to be at this debate
chill dude
a few more hours on standby I have a
shield
don't look at 65 degrees out here you've
sweated me or one of em pupils are
dilated you [ __ ] if I checked your
heart rate you'd be over 100 how do you
see me diagnosing for the hospital I'm
fine plain English you're acting like a
dick and your veal what are you popping
mota Red's not wrong
that's the thing about drug addicts see
kindred spirits where they don't exist
you